[Music]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday April
26th today's video blog comes in five
parts part one pawpaw it's his birthday
you need to call him part two speaking
of old people Helen Hunt is on your
guilt-free three list Helen Hunt Helen
Hunt Hank I'd just like to remind you
that cougar hunting is not legal in the
United States but anyway Hank you're
talking about your celebrity do list as
another commenter called it reminded me
of number three my own celebrity do list
which I keep of course in my copy of how
to be a lady in your pants now let's see
if we can find it in here oh there it is
okay Hank we have Natalie Portman
perfectly acceptable jenna fischer from
the office Pam the only thing I like
more than the idea of Pam and Jim
getting together Pam and John getting
together then of course we have Judy
Blume
I mean she's cute she's really cute and
one time at a conference you kissed me
on the cheek and I liked it and I liked
her and I'm not gonna talk about any
more okay maybe you get a pass on Helen
Hunt part for moving Hank I'm sorry to
hear that your house is on the block I
have good news though I think that you
should buy a house but not in Missoula
specifically I think you should buy a
house in Indianapolis Indiana you want
to know why because I'm moving there
Sarah got a job at the Indianapolis
Museum of Art which is really one of the
most exciting contemporary art spaces in
America and we're really psyched to go
there but I'm a little worried because I
don't have any friends in Indianapolis
and I think I'm going to miss New York
although if you think about it
Indianapolis is like the New York of
Indiana and also I'm told that it's got
really good Orban exploring plus
yesterday I was looking on the internet
and houses in Indianapolis are almost
free part 5 Hank I liked your eco geek
podcast animation introduction so much
that I've been thinking that maybe we
could have a shorter more visual
animation for Brotherhood 2.0 that maybe
doesn't spell communication wrong
maybe you were one of the nerdfighters
can get on it I do it myself except I'm
bad at animating and plus I have to
figure out how I'm going to move to
Indianapolis with all of these books
Hank I'll see you tomorrow